ideas
que vale la pena difundir cuando una
idea merece ser difundida una idea
es buena por sí sola
un contexto inapropiado puede arruinar
una idea
una idea simple con un contexto muy
motivador puede funcionar
tengo un piano acá
y en la música existen ideas por ejemplo
si yo toco esto
a
sabio algunas damas de la platea
suspirando porque es una idea
maravillosa
quien no conoce para elisa de beethoven
ahora esta idea precisa un contexto del
contexto en el piano en este caso lo
hace la mano izquierda de la mano
izquierda la compañía y toca
[Música]
perfecto ya tengo una idea ya tengo el
contexto entonces sólo me resta unirlas
para que quede
[Aplausos]
i
algo está mal sobrando de cuenta que
esto no puede ser beethoven lo que está
mal es que la melodía la idea está en
una tonalidad pero el contexto está en
otro en la vida real nos pasa mucho uno
siente que tiene una idea pero que el
contexto está en otra tonalidad si yo el
contexto en lugar de hacerlo así
lo modificó y lo ubicó en la misma
frecuencia la tonalidad que la idea
y parece que las cosas empieza a
funcionar
pero el ejemplo
es muy fácil si la idea es tan
maravillosa como esta que tuvo beethoven
pero imagínense que viene un chico y me
dice
o la fe me dicen no sé por qué pero hola
efe mira yo quiero ser compositor y
compuse mi primera obra mira para acá
está la idea que tengo
[Música]
y yo les digo si sin él es muy lindo me
hace acordar a la historia del padre que
hace estudiar a violín a el chico y lo
lleva a un amigo le dice mira juanes
gusta como toca violín mi hijo y el hijo
toca violín muy feo y le dice qué te
parece la ejecución mala ejecución un
poco exagerado un par de bofetadas os
alcanzaría
pero bueno no en el caso
sin pensar en vos pitazos se me ocurrió
decir esta idea
dagán el filo dedícate a otra cosa pero
si es cnn era frédéric chopin compositor
polaco del siglo 19 podía haber escrito
bueno
y con esa idea tan sencilla que daba
para el boletazo hizo un preludio el
preludio a mi menor una obra maravillosa
que se toca en todos los recitales de
piano
así que vimos los dos ejemplos y qué
pasa si yo digo tengo una idea voy a ser
compositor mi idea es esta
[Música]
qué les parece
escucho risas cuidado que las risas
pueden ser irrespetuosa porque yo esté
esta idea la por repetible ya se empieza
a tener o está incluso puede modificar
el ritmo el ritmo es la duración de las
notas se puede hacer eso si soy tom
jobim por ejemplo el compositor
brasileño pudo hacer
es la samba de una nota sola se habrán
dado cuenta porque el título ahora
esta samba dura no está sola
explota casi al máximo la idea de una
idea valga la redundancia reducida a la
expresión de una sola nota pero hablando
de reducir ideas hay un ejemplo que es
casi paradigmático el ejemplo más
interesante de síntesis de una idea que
lo produjo john cage compositor de una
obra para piano que se llama cuatro
minutos 33 segundos y en este caso para
ser fiel a la obra voy a utilizar la
partitura si ustedes me permiten
bueno
y voy a ejecutar solamente un fragmento
porque damos el tiempo sabemos que es
y bueno podemos continuar pero con esto
hay una versión que es por ahí más
intensa pero menos interesante para
orquesta que si quieren pueden escuchar
y también hablando de ideas en la música
se me ocurre pensar hasta aquel momento
una idea es propia
es totalmente propia y en qué momento la
idea empieza a ser un poco compartida
hay un área de mods arts de la ópera don
giovanni don giovanni con juan la
historia de el varón que quiere
encontrar todas las mujeres en una y por
eso conquista una y después la otra y la
otra que siempre se queda insatisfecho
el área es la archi daré en la mano en
donde don giovanni le canta a una de sus
amadas ven y te daré la mano nos iremos
muy lejos etc
vos lo vas a aceptar y el área es más o
menos así sí no
la medida
sí no
contando
el reino del revés
[Música]
es muy similar
este es un ejemplo dudoso porque decimos
esta idea estaba de antes es nueva pero
hay un compositor en donde claramente
podemos decir que encuentra las cosas
antes de que se pierda un eufemismo para
decir que robe a un compositor un
compositor popular digamos que
se quedó sin inspiración tampoco había
tenido mucha inspiración en las obras
previas pero en este caso él quería
tener inspiración entonces buscó en su
vieja fono la en sus viejos discos de
pasta a los más jóvenes dijo que antes
no era un pendrive de bronce de eran
vinilo no y este disco de pasta lo
colocó para ver si se inspiraba en un
disco de un tango
estaba rayado no servía entonces lo tiro
y busco otro y leyó en la tapa muzio
clémenti sonatina en sol mayor quien va
a conocer a muchos le mentí bueno mucho
clemente es un compositor fabuloso mucho
menos famoso de lo que su genio hubiera
merecido fue maestro de beethoven entre
otros y en el tercer movimiento de esta
sonata
que este compositor popular buscaba para
inspirarse escribió de esto
[Música]
y este compositor dijo no me gusta mucho
algo está mal acá que es este botoncito
algún botón que tenía tres números 33 45
y 78
78,78 debe estar mal esto lo pongo en 45
[Música]
tampoco me gusta así a ver qué pasa en
[Aplausos]
y quien quien me va a denunciar
muzio clémenti se murió hace más de
doscientos trescientos años y se va a
acordar quién va a conocer salud algún
imbécil que va a salten investigue estas
cosas
ahora es un esfuerzo de traducción
siempre se desplazó latina no termina
ahí
sigue
entonces el próximo hit dice
[Música]
una deja de insistir al haber chin
y listo con eso lo público y nos
llenamos de plata todo ahora bien una
vez escuché hablando de ideas ahora que
era el tema escucha alejandro dolina de
es decir el genio no fue el que inventó
el teléfono
genial fue que inventó el segundo
teléfono porque la verdad que un
teléfono solo no tiene
y en el caso de las ideas pasa lo mismo
los compositores algunos tienen ideas
geniales pero los compositores que son
geniales son los que encuentran el
segundo teléfono para cada idea y en ese
sentido uno de mis favoritos y uno de
los más grandes es sin duda mozart a
quien escuchamos antes en la escuchaba
citamos antes en las el área en la mano
que compuso una sonata en do mayor una
sonata para piano que bien puede ser una
idea de contar una historia y esta idea
y por eso se encadena empieza así
empieza como cuando nacemos
y vamos a después del jardín
jugamos
[Música]
con los chicos con los amigos
crecemos ya terminamos la escuela
primero la primaria y de repente aparece
ella
[Música]
yo cuando conoce a mi mujer le dije
apenas la conocí me gusta tocar el piano
y le dije te gusta la música me dijo 'te
sí pero no importa seguir tocando
la precisa
[Música]
está todo bien salimos
a tomar un café
a pasarla juntos muy bien
y estamos siempre muy contentos y este
es el momento en donde hay que decirle
así que te gusta que yo sea músico si te
gusta que sea joven mío que no me
interese lo material mexicano es
firmarlo
porque yo quiero tener registros porque
esto tiene
está por terminar
que hicimos
juntos
y no empezamos en salir
y una más fechas
y empezó el matrimonio
[Música]
pero es muy raro
en moto
empezamos cal
a los chicos el trabajo
la casa
[Música]
y lo principal y si está la vida que es
la vida que quiero y uno que quiere es
volver a ese comienzo cuando era chico
digamos esto es como el comienzo pero
comienzo así y ahora es así
no es lo mismo pero no es lo mismo ahora
tenemos unos kilos de más
un poco menos de pelo el otro día se
paró mi nene yo estaba sentada y me dijo
papá se te ve el piso
y yo dije es cierto porque estamos en la
recapitulación
pero uno de igual disfrutar y busca los
chicos crecieron reencontrarse con esa
persona que conoció
[Música]
y resto siente que la encuentra
pero como era antes
[Música]
también es parecidos
qué va a hacer yo también fui más gordo
jugamos salimos no nos quedamos acá
[Música]
no es tan feo doctor fauci
grabada que utilísima las recetas
me contáis de asado al horno
[Música]
y así camina
hablando de ideas en la música ideas que
se encadenan quizás que estamos acá en
confianza que tenemos no se entera a
nadie
yo le propongo entre todos hacer un hit
vamos a hacer un tema que se venda y
después repartimos la regalía en total
nadie se sentirá preparado tener un hit
tenemos que tener una idea
y una idea pueden ser tres notas las
notas musicales son 72 re mi fa sol así
hay alteraciones vemos el sostenido
porque importa
digamos vamos a entre todos a generar
una idea de tres sonidos por ejemplo de
este lugar do re mi fa sol así una nota
[Música]
perfecto
y
porque la gente
[Música]
y ustedes son la segunda nota
si bemol sostenido sólo vemos si bemol
[Música]
se va queriendo va queriendo y haber
aquí el sector otra nota rey sostenido
bemol sólo vemos
y ya tenemos la idea y para que venda
porque la hora que lo único que nos
interesa en este caso es hacer un hit es
venderlo recaudar mucho así que hagamos
algo popular por ejemplo
un bolero qué les parece
e
discúlpeme este yo voy corriendo los
camarógrafos saben lo que pasa
que si es un bolero como no hacen el
texto el texto que tiene que ser parte
del horario por lo menos esta idea tiene
que tener un texto que palabra podemos
este a ver
no pero saben que yo les decimos algo
que aprendí con los años de mucho
estudio si la nota la idea tiene tres
notas el texto tiene que tener tres
sílabas en ese ente del río de la plata
no hay forma yo no sé si alguna vez max
o si te ocurre una palabra como este por
alguna palabra para el bolero estamos
generando un hit ahí pero si algo para
hacer un dibujito tres notas una palabra
cuál es un bolero es ambición
ahí está ambición ambición de querer
transmisión de tener transmisión de no
sé qué entonces vamos a hacer una cosa
segunda como el aire ya no abrimos
funcionamos cantando se les pidió que
digan ambición cantando más te mata
vamos a ver
[Música]
tenemos una pequeña dificultad y
respiramos bien lo hacemos de vuelta
de vuelta buenísimos ahora voy a cenar
el resto en el medio pero cuando venga
el tema ahí lo hacemos lo que hacemos
fuertes palitos a ver
empezamos con ambición
i
talará
ahí va
[Música]
y para que sea un verdadero hits esto
tiene que terminar con una ovación
porque si no la gente va a pensar porque
estamos grabando en vivo ahora para
después lo pueden comprar a la salida lo
digital instamos entonces todo este
sector va a sonar una especie de como de
ensayos del aplauso ovación es así
ustedes hacen eso ustedes empiezan a
cantar pero a medida que ellos van
creciendo empiezan a dejar de cantar y
aplaudir cada vez más así terminamos
todo para arriba
a río de la plata a ver cómo sale
empezando el aplauso ovación se está
grabando por favor seriedad
y
ah
[Música]
i
[Aplausos]
[Música]
más